let's imagine that you work for a major
streaming media provider right so you
have I know some 100 million drivers so
you've got I don't know ten thousand
videos on your site or many more audio
files right so for each user you're
gonna have collected information on what
they've watched when they've watched it
how long they've watched it for whether
they went from this one to this one did
that work was that good for them and so
maybe you've got 30,000 data points per
user we're now talking about trillions
of data points and your job is to try
and predict what someone wants to watch
or listen to next best of luck
so we've cleaned the data we've
transformed our data everything's on the
same scale we've joined data sets
together the problem is because we've
joined data sets together perhaps our
data set has got quite large right now
or maybe we just work for a company that
has a lot a lot of data certainly the
general consensus these days is to
collect as much data as you can like
this isn't always a good idea we what we
want remember it's the smallest most
compact and useful data set we can
otherwise you're just going to be
wasting CPU hours or GPU hours training
on this wasting time we want to get to
the knowledge as quickly as possible and
if you can do that with a small amount
of data that's going to be great so
we've got quite an interesting data set
to look at today based on music it's
quite common these days when you're
building something like a streaming
service for example Spotify you might
want to have a recommender system this
is an idea where you've maybe clustered
people who are similar in their tastes
you know what kind of music they're
listening to and you know the attributes
of that music and if you know that you
can say well this person likes high
tempo music so maybe he'd like this
track as well and this is how playlists
are generated one of the problems is
that you're gonna have to produce
descriptions of the audio on things like
tempo and how upbeat they are in order
to machine learn on this kind of system
right and that's what this data sets
about so we've collected a dataset here
today that is lots and lots of metadata
on music tracks right now these are
freely available tracks and freely
available data and put a link in the
description if you want to have a look
at it yourself I've cleaned it up a bit
already because obviously I've been
through the process of cleaning and
transforming my data so we're gonna load
this now this takes quite a long time to
do
because there's quite a lot of
attributes and quite a lot of instances
it's loaded right how much is this data
well we've got 13,500 observations
that's instances and we've got seven
hundred and sixty-two attributes right
so that means another way of putting
this if in sort of machine learning
parlance is we've got thirteen thousand
instances and 760 features now these
features are a combination of things so
let's have a quick look at the columns
we're looking at so we can see what this
data sets about so names of music all
right so we've got some 760 features or
attributes and you can see there's a lot
of slightly meaningless text here but if
we look at the top you'll see some
actual things that may be familiar to us
so we've got the track ID album ID the
genre right so Jean was an interesting
one because maybe we can start to use
some of these audio descriptions to
predict what Jean with its music is or
something like that things like the
track number and the track duration and
then we get on to the actual audio
description features now these have been
generated by two different libraries the
first is called Lib rosa which is a
publicly available library for taking an
mp3 and calculating musical sort of
attributes of it what we're trying to do
here is represent our data in terms of
attributes an mp3 file is not an
attribute it's a lot of data so can we
summarize it in some way can we
calculate by looking at the mp3 what the
tempo is what the amplitude is how loud
the track is these kind of things this
is a kind of thing we're measuring and a
lot of these are going to go into a lot
of detail down at kind of a waveform
level so we have the Lib Roza features
first and then if we scroll down after a
while we'd get to some echo nest
features echinus is a company that
produces very interesting features on
music and actually these are the
features that power Spotify is
recommender system and numerous others
we've got things like acoustic nurse how
a coup stick does it sound
we've got instrumental nurse I'm not
convinced that the word speech enos
their hat hat to what extent is it
speech or not speech and then things
like tempo how fast is it and valence
how happy does it sound right a track of
zero would be quite sad I guess and a
track of one will be really high happy
and upbeat and then of course we've got
a load of features I've labeled temporal
here and these are going to be based on
the actual music data themselves often
when we talk about data reduction
we're actually using its dimensionality
reduction right well way of thinking
about it is we as we started we've been
looking at things like attributes and
we've been saying what is the mean or a
standard deviation of some attribute on
our data but actually when we start to
talk about clustering and machine
learning we're going to talk a little
bit more about dimensions now this is in
many ways the number of attributes is
the number of dimensions it's just
another term for the same thing but
certainly from a machine learning
background we refer to a lot of these
things as dimensions so you can imagine
if you've got some data here so you've
got your instances down here and you've
got your attributes across here so in
this case our music data we've got each
song so this is puts on one this is on
two song three and then all the
attributes of a temple echo nest
attributes its tempo and things like
this these are all dimensions in which
this data can vary so they can be
different in the first dimension which
is the track ID but they can also down
here be different in this dimension
which is for tempo when we say some data
is seven hundred dimensional what that
actually means is it has seven hundred
different ways or different attributes
in which it can vary and you can imagine
that first of all this is going to get
quite big quite quickly my seven hundred
a tribute seems like a lot to me right
and depending on what the algorithm
you're running is it can get quite slow
when you're running oh this kind of size
of data and you can maybe this is a
relatively small data set compared to
what Spotify might deal with on a daily
basis but another way to think about
this data is actually points in this
space so we have some 700 different
attributes that you can vary and when we
take a specific track it sits somewhere
in this space so if we were looking at
it in just two dimensions you know a
track one might be over here and track
two over here and track three over here
and in three dimensions track four might
be back at the back here you can imagine
the more dimensions we add the further
spread out these things are going to get
but we can still do all the same things
we can in three dimensions in 700
dimensions it just takes a little bit
longer so one of the problems is that
some things like machine learning don't
like to have too many dimensions so
things like linear regression can get
quite slow if you have tens of thousands
of attributes or dimensions so remember
that perhaps the the default response to
anyone collecting data is just deflect
it all and worry about it later this is
a time reporting when you have to worry
about it what we're trying to do is
move any redundant variables if you've
got two attributes of your music like
tempo and valence that turn out to be
exactly the same why are we using Bo for
making our problem a little bit harder
right now in actual fact echo nests
features are pretty good they don't tend
to correlate that strongly but you might
find where we've collected some data on
a big scale actually a lot of it
variables are very very similar all the
time and you can just remove some of
them or combine some of them together
and just make your problem a little bit
easier so let's look at this on the
music data set and see what we can do so
the first thing we can do is we could
remove duplicates Ryba sounds like an
obvious one and perhaps one that we
could also do during cleaning but
exactly when you do it doesn't really
matter as long as you're paying
attention what we're going to say is
music all equals unique of music all and
what that's going to do is look for find
any duplicate rows and remove them the
number of rows we've got will drop by
some amount let's see thinking it's
where you live timer
actually this is quite a slow process
you've got to consider that we're going
to look through every single row and try
and find any other rows that match okay
so this is removed a bit about 40 rows
so this meant we had some duplicate
tracks you can imagine that things might
get accidentally added to the database
twice or maybe two tracks are actually
identical because they were released
multiple times or something like this
now what this is doing the unique
function actually finds rows that are
exactly the same for every single
attribute or every single dimension of
course in practice you might find that
you have two versions of the same track
which differ by one second they might
have slightly different attributes
hopefully they'll be very very similar
so what we could also do is have a
threshold where we said these are too
similar they're the same thing the name
is the same the artist is the same and
the audio descriptors are very very
similar maybe we should just remove one
of them well this is the other thing you
could do just for demonstration what
we're going to do is focus on just a few
of the genres in this data set right
just to make things a little bit clearer
for visualizations we're going to select
just the classical jazz pop and
spoken-word genres right because these
have a good distribution of different
amounts in the data set so we're going
to run that we're creating a list of
genres we're going to say music is
musical where any time where the genre
is in that list of genres we just
produced and that's going to produce a
much smaller dataset of 1,600
observations the same number of
attributes or dimensions now normally
you would obviously keep most of your
data in this is just for a demonstration
but removing genres that aren't useful
to you for your experiment is a
perfectly reasonable way of reducing
your data size if that's a problem
assuming they've been labeled right in
the first place right that's on someone
else that's someone else's job let's
imagine but 1,600 is still too long now
actually computers are getting pretty
quick maybe 1,600 observations is fine
but perhaps we want to remove some more
the first thing we could do is just chop
off the day to half way and keep about
half so let's try that first of all so
we're going to say the first music
that's the first few rows of our music
is rows 1 to 835 and all the columns so
we're going to run that and that's even
smaller right so we can start to whittle
down our data this is not necessarily a
good idea we're assuming here
that our genre is equally you know
randomly sampled around our data set
that might not be true you might have
all the lock first and then all the pop
or something like that if you take the
first few you're just going to get all
the rock right depending on what you
like that might not be for you so let's
plot these on was in the normal data set
and you can see that we've got very
little spoken word but it is there
we have some classical international
jazz and pop in sort of roughly the same
amount if we plot after we've selected
the first 50 you can see we've lost two
of the genres like we only have
classical international and jazz and
there's hardly any jazz that's not a
good idea so don't do that
unless you know that your data is
randomized so this is not this is not
giving us a good representation of
genres if we wanted to predict jonatha
for example based on the musical
features cutting out half the genres
seems like an unwise decision so a
better thing to do will be to sample
randomly from the data set so what we're
going to do is we're going to use the
sample function to give us 835 random
indices into this data and then we're
going to use that the index our music
data frame instead
alright that's this line here and
hopefully this will give us a better
distribution if we plot the original
again it looks like this and you can see
we've got a broad distribution and then
if we plot the randomized version you
can see we've still got some spoken it's
actually going up slightly but the
distributions are broadly the same so
this is worked exactly how we want so
how you select your data if you're
trying to make it a little bit smaller
it's very very important and consider
but obviously we only had 1,600 here and
even the human is whole data set is only
1,300 rows you could imagine that you
might have tens of millions of rows and
you've got to think about this before
you start just getting rid of them
completely randomized sampling is is a
perfectly good way of selecting your
data obviously it has a risk that maybe
if the distributions of your genres are
a little bit off and maybe you haven't
got very much of a certain genre you
can't guarantee that the distributions
are going to be the same on the way out
and if you're trying to predict Jama
that's going to be a problem so perhaps
the best approach is stratified sampling
this is where we try and maintain the
distribution of our classes so for
example in this case genre so we could
say we all
we had 50% Rock 30% pop and 20% spoken
and we want to maintain that kind of
distribution on the way out even if we
only saw about 50% right this is a
little bit more complicated in our but
it can be done and this is a good
approach if you want to make absolutely
sure with distributions of your sample
data are the same as your original data
we just looked at some ways we can
reduce the size of our data set in terms
of a number of instances or the number
of rows can we make the number of
dimensions or the number of attributes
smaller because that's often one of the
problems and the answer is yes and
there's lots of different ways we can do
this some more powerful and useful than
others one of the ways we can do this is
something called correlation analysis so
a correlation between two attributes
basically tells us that when one of them
increases the other one either increases
or decreases in general in relation to
it so you might have some data like this
we've actually won and we might have
attribute two and they sort of look like
this these are the data points for all
of our different data obviously we've
got a lot of data points and you can see
that roughly speaking they kind of
increase in this sort of direction here
like this now it might be but if this
correlation is very very strong so
basically attribute to is a copy of
attribute one more or less maybe it
doesn't make sense to have attribute two
in our data set maybe we can remove it
without too much of a problem what we
can do is something called correlation
analysis where we pitch all of the
attributes versus all of the other
attributes we look for high correlations
and we decide ourselves whether to
remove them now sometimes it's useful
just to keep everything in and try not
to remove them too early but on the
other hand if you've got a huge amount
of data and your correlations are very
high this could be one way of doing it
another option is something called
forward or backward attribute selection
now this is the idea that maybe we have
a machine learning model or clustering
algorithm in mind we can measure the
performance of that and then we can
remove features and see if the
performance remains the same because if
it does maybe we didn't need those
features so what we could do is we could
train our model on let's say a 720
dimensional data set and then we could
get a certain level of accuracy and
record that then we could try it again
by removing one of the dimensions and
try on 719 and maybe the accuracy is
exactly the same in which case we can
say well we didn't really need that
dimension at all and we can start to
whittle down are they
set this way another option is forwards
attribute selection this is where we
literally train our machine learning on
just one of the attributes and then we
see what our accuracy is and we keep
adding attributes in and Retraining
until our performance plateaus and we
can say you know what we're not gaining
anything now by adding more attributes
obviously there's the question of which
order do you tribus in usually bandim
lee so what you would do is you would
train on all the data for example of a
backwards attribute selection you take
one out at random if your performance
stays the same you can leave it out if
your performance gets much worse you put
it back in and you don't try that one
again and you try a different one and
you stole slowly start to take
dimensions away and hopefully Whittle
Daniel data let's have a quick look at
correlation analysis on this data set
you might imagine that if we're
calculating features based on the mp3
from Lib rosa or echo nest maybe they're
quite similar a lot of the time and
maybe we can remove them let's have a
quick look so we're just going to focus
on one of a set of Lib rosa features
just for simplicity so we're going to
select only the attributes that contain
this chroma kurtosis field which is one
of the attributes that you can calculate
using Lib rosa so I'm going to run that
we're going to rename them just for a
home simplicity to Kurt one Kurt - Kurt
3 and then we're going to calculate a
correlation matrix of each of these
different features versus each other
like this ok finally we're going to plot
this and see what it looks like
hopefully we can find some good
correlations and we could have
candidates for just removing a few of
these dimensions if it's redundant and
it's not too bad so you can see that
we've got for example Kurt 7 here so
index 7 is fairly similar to 8 that's a
correlation of 0.65 maybe that means
that we could remove one over two of
those this one here is 0.5 nine we've
got a point four eight over here these
are fairly high correlations if you're
really stretched for CPU time or you're
worried about a size of your data set
this is the kind of thing you could do
to remove them of course wherever point
six five is a strong enough correlation
that you want to delete and completely
remove one of these dimensions it's
really up to you and it's going to
depend on your situation one of the
reasons that the correlations aren't
quite as hard as you might think is that
these libraries have been designed with
this in mind if you just if echo nests
just produce 200 feet
all exactly the same it wouldn't be very
useful for picking playlists so they've
produced 200 features that are widely
different so we're not necessarily going
to correlate all the time right that's
the whole point and that's a really
useful feature of this data we've looked
at some ways we can try and make our
data set a little bit smaller
remember our ultimate goal is a smallest
most sort of useful data we can get our
hands on right then we can put that into
machine learning or clustering and
really extract some knowledge the
problem is that what we might do may
based on correlation analysis or forward
backwards attribute selection we might
just be deleting data and maybe the
correlation wasn't one it wasn't
completely redundant do we actually want
to completely remove this data is there
another way we can transform our data to
make more informed decisions as to what
we remove and more effective ones that's
PCA or principal component analysis at
the moment we're just fitting one line
through our two-dimensional data there's
going to be more principal components
later right but what we want to do is we
want to pick the direction through this
data however many attributes it has that
has the most spread so how do we measure
this well quite simply